guten morgen aus berlin nachdem ich das
gesagt habe dann der gärtner im garten
sich einfach mal gedacht sein
laubgebläse anzuschmeißen war ganz stark
ich setzt sich auf jeden fall im auto
zusammen mit david und zwar fragt ihr
euch bestimmt warum ich in berlin bin
und zwar bin ich in berlin im rahmen der
kampagne mein campus studieren in
fernost
das ist eine kampagne wo verschiedene
hochschulen und unis einfach in
ostdeutschland gezeigt werden wie ihr
wisst ihr ich selber und deswegen finde
ich ganz cool mal mir das mal
anzuschauen was es sonst noch für sachen
geb ich studier halten sehr bwl lastigen
modul studiengängen kann genau sagen wir
schauen uns auf jeden fall verschiedene
hochschulen also nicht nur
eindimensionale sachen wohl nur bbl
angeboten wird oder so sondern irgendwie
videospiel design meine ich es dabei
soundtechnik dann zum motion capture
sachen aber das wird jetzt auf jeden
fall alles noch dem video wir sind jetzt
gerade wer im büro angekommen das ist
der standort wo die hochschule harz ist
wir stehen hier gerade vor den gebäuden
für wirtschaftswissenschaften das kann
man hier unter anderem auch studieren
was wir uns allerdings anschauen ist der
studiengang medieninformatik wo wir so
sachen machen werden wie steadycam
rumprobieren motion capture komischen
sachen rum fahren und da fangen jetzt
einfach mal mit an sebastian und robin
richtig die haben mir grad erklärt wie
man diese fähigkeit teil benutzt es ist
nämlich kamerafahrten in cool ich habe
jetzt hier die kamera an mir dran und
auch dieses dicke steadycam ding und ich
versuche gerade als erste übung diese
steadycam auf einer höhe zu halten
man kann halt richtig schlecht euro und
die verlagerung von dem gewicht geht
einfach überhaupt nicht klar man jetzt
geht die wieder von mir weg
es ist es viel schwieriger als es
einfach aussieht
herztier und nach auf den bildschirm
gucken
das ist ein bildschirm wie der
historische dort damals hatten
vier tage
jetzt schon gesehen wie das rad bei mir
außer das war einfach so recht wacklig
ja so sieht richtig auch wenn man es
nicht für macht wie ich offen
so
also der studiengang medieninformatik
jedes semester suchen uns zeit zwei
leute die in der steadycam ausgebildet
werden können
wir sind jetzt gerade hier motion
capture bereichen ich habe mir gerade
einfach ein punkte anzug angezogen und
habe hier sogar eine kappe mit so drauf
an und dir hier ist sind überall kameras
irgendwie zwölf stück waren das noch
punkte hier werden an dabei quasi die
textet und wenn ich außerhalb des
bereiches bin ist das alles ein bisschen
gucken ich mal schauen ob ich jetzt auf
irgend eine figur modelliert werde und
hier dann irgendwas machen können
nachdem jetzt gerade bei motion capture
wann werde ich jetzt hier gerade schon
ganz cool rumgefahren und zwar bin ich
auch so das ist der genaue name von dem
ding volley ball genau ich sitze gerade
auf einem dolly und werte gerade um
seinen typischen vorlesungs raum
rumgefahren also sieht das ganze mal aus
hier vorne werden sachen darauf
projiziert da hinten haben wir auch so
einem greenscreen studio und ich werde
gar die ganze zeit herum gefahren
können sie eigentlich täglich so machen
also ganz entspannt wow ich kann um die
komplette camera raw
jetzt bin ich hier
viele hier ich bin total fasziniert ihr
würden
das war's jetzt von der hochschule harz
wir haben auf jeden fall richtig geile
sachen macht also das mit motion capture
fand ich richtig gerne und vor allem der
steadycam das ist einfach so 25 kilo
wiegt oder so wir sind jetzt gerade auf
dem rückweg und zwar ich hätte auch
ehrlich gesagt nie gedacht dass hartz
ist so schön sein kann oder crazy
gewesen vor also ich bin jetzt einfach
mal ein paar szenen ein wo wir
beispielsweise gerade vorbeigefahren
sind wir am rathaus oder an einfach der
altstadt so ein bisschen und jetzt
gerade sind auf dem rückweg guten morgen
aus babelsberg meine lieben freunde wir
sind nämlich gerade in babel jeden fall
stehen hier vor der film universität
babelsberg und werden dort heute so ein
paar sachen lernen die szenografie sound
techniken design et cetera oder gehe ich
jetzt mal reinkommen mit oder mitschüler
was mich da erwartet
wir sind jetzt hier in einem kleinen
kino angekommen so sieht das ganze aus
also wie wir schauen uns jetzt hier
gleich ein paar filme an werden danach
dann noch mal schauen ob ich selbst
irgendwas machen kann und hier werden
unter anderem auch filme gedreht die
sind nämlich neben anderen paar
filmstudios kulissen direkt aufgebaut
und da werde ich nachher versuchen auch
noch was filmen zu können
der film den ich gesehen habe wurde
quasi auch komplett an dieser
universität in dieser film universität
gemacht also alles vom design vom sound
von der konzeption von der regie von der
story direction keine ahnung was da
sonst gibt es wird auf jeden fall alles
hier gemacht man kann hier von bachelor
über master alles studieren was
irgendwie mit filmton sah und schauspiel
zu tun hat jedenfalls als ich fragte wer
das ist
relativ hoch und zwar stehen jetzt
irgendwie am höchsten punkt von der film
universität und man sieht ja auch
verschiedene sachen beispielsweise dahin
sind vier verschiedene
aufnahme hans thon kreuzes relativ alt
da hinten sind so antike aufnahme
szenarien wo man irgendwie
mittelalterliche szenen drehen kann
hier vorne sind zwei aufnahme hier vorne
mit gzsz gefilmt dahinter sind zur
kaputte karte loslegen mit dem film
dahinter und moneymanagement gedreht
also wirklich mega crash passiert schon
alles gedreht wurde was ja auch in
zukunft noch gedreht wird ich will jetzt
noch eine stunde hier und ich habe schon
soviel einfach gelernt über film also
mega krass es gibt ja auch tatsächlich
so zimmer wo wirklich die studenten die
hier studieren wenn sie dann mal nachts
überstunden einlegen und auf einem film
arbeiten dass sie tatsächlich die penan
können und die arbeiten können hier
essen können und wirklich halt echt
übernachten können wenn die quasi
solange noch andere filme weil wir
schauen uns jetzt nochmal die
studiengänge sound und szenografie an
und schau mal ob ich da vielleicht auch
irgendwie was man machen kann vielleicht
irgendwas aufnehmen kann
vielleicht bei gzsz mit hannes kratzer
an dieser uni jetzt halt einfach auch
gegenüber also brücken im gelände und
hier unten ist jetzt einfach mal so eine
brutale garten die irgendwie auch alles
voll mit natur und hier unten sind auch
so filmstudium blöcke wo wir gleich mal
reingehen werden
das heißt es etwa
ja
den wein
nicht viel darüber wie finger wir sind
jetzt hier mit atelier- und zwar was
hier gemacht wird ist die ganzen
verschiedenen soundeffekte werden
aufeinander gemischt quasi also hier
wird gerade einem interaktiven film
gearbeitet
die form wird alles aufeinander gelegt
und die können quasi einfach beim sound
effect sagen das weiß ich anderen wir
uns aus dem autoradio kommt oder aus
einem megaphon oder keine ahnung was
einfach mega cool ist wir beschäftigen
uns jetzt mit dem studiengang
szenografie szenografie es quasi das
dass die leute die damit vertraut sind
bekommen quasi vor dem film vor allem
anderen das drehbuch und entwickeln
quasi seine zum design zum aufbau seiner
struktur von szenen bau quasi vor dem
film hier wird das ganze dann gebaut in
diesem raum also beispielsweise der star
wars
sie bekommen gesagt das traumschiff muss
rechteckig sein es muss rund seien keine
ahnung was und die bauen an dem
entsprechenden raumschiff
dementsprechend so dementsprechend
dementsprechend diese einen das halt und
dann wird das beim beispiel star wars
dann halt visuell nachgebaut also die
bilden quasi die szene und da gehen wir
jetzt mal unten irgendwo hin wo das
ganze gerade in action gemacht wird
im rahmen von studioprojekt das machen
wir einmal unsere karriere wenn man so
will dann der unten in dem fall
eigentlich ein dschungel den wir
versuchen zu errichten der sich dann
aber letztendlich auflöst eigentlich in
den ganzen set und in einem ganz
normalen raum stattfinde das wird sie
eigentlich zu sehen ist alles gut machen
kann mit den einfachsten kindergarten
mit den wenn man so ein cooles seiten zu
erzeugen
doch freunde das war es ja an der film
universität babelsberg richtig richtig
richtig es war auf jeden fall richtig
cool also wir haben echt einiges über
szenografie und vor allem auch über
sound gelernt und allgemeinen wie viel
arbeit die in so einem film gesteckt
wird also ich dachte wirklich immer ja
okay da steckt mehr arbeit und ein
youtube video das klar aber das hat
wirklich eine dame ja das ist jetzt mein
zehn minuten film da habe ich jetzt
schon 20 stunden dran gearbeitet ich bin
noch immer nicht fertig und das ist
total so reale zeiten einfach mieten wie
lange die einfach in diesen studios sind
aber es sieht alles megaspaß ich aus
also unglaublich kreative leute da bin
einfach nur beeindruckt gerade das als
die film universität babelsberg morgen
fahren wir zur fh brandenburg und da
sehen wir uns dann wieder
wir sind jetzt gerade bei der
fachhochschule brandenburg angekommen wo
wir uns den studiengang informatik
anschauen werden wo viele sachen mit
digitalen medien behandelt werden game
dieser in motion capture augmented
reality und das schauen uns jetzt mal an
mit der biblischen alter so krass ist
die hände erkennt
das was wir gerade gesehen habt war lieb
motion da konnte ich quasi meine hände
so an so einen sensor halten und dann
wurden die halt in game erkannt was ja
gerade auch in den zehn eingeladen
gesehen hab jetzt sitzen wir gerade mit
einem studenten hier der selber eine app
entwickelt hat so sieht das ganze hier
aus ist man kann selber auch quasi drauf
drücken und mit dem spiel interagieren
hat schon sehr viel zeit investiert
vorbereiter schon drei monaten zur
umsetzung generell ein halbes jahr
borken kreis was für monster was für die
kultur in was für wasser und wirklich
dieses monster auszeichnen
und jetzt wird's in den charts webster
einer menge arbeit
es ist krass ist einfach komplett von
dir ist
ich sehe euch zwei grad nicht aber ich
habe gerade sondern wie nennt sich das
genau nochmal das hab ich ja auch das
ist so in das ist so ähnlich wie die
oculus und zwar ich sehe gerade wenn ich
mich um gucke eine palme großen bösen
typen diskutiert nicht sind aber dass
gerade richtig crazy es ist richtig cool
wenn ich nein man kann sich nicht mal
die augen zuhalten jungen es passiert
hier gucken auf dem boden
für die kultur frau
nein nein bitte nicht
ja genau
dann stellt sich seit echt musikforum
beim ein kleiner bildschirm hat man die
tectum raum man sieht halt komplett
ja wahrscheinlich hat man ihn töten
können
da schon mal aufgefallen
wir sind jetzt gerade aus erfahrung
schule raus gegangen wir haben hier
vorne einen kleinen roboter namens david
mit dem ich gleich ein bisschen romand
ihren werde hier oben wird die drohne
und zwar ist das die band um drei
drohnen namen drohne hat keinen
richtigen namen und wir werden damit
jetzt gucken was man damit so alles
anstellen kann und die drohne fischer
ist die ganze zeit rum
david ich dann redet mit mir
fortitudo gossau euro ich sitze jetzt
hier vor dem gebäude wo wir grad drin
waren und wo ich mit dem kleinen roboter
namens pay wird ein bisschen herum
gelaufen bin heute war es nicht richtig
krass geil also die letzten tag was auch
super und aber heute war es halt echt
mit diesem roboter um laufen deshalb
nicht
da sieht man wieder wie krass weit die
technik einfach schon ist jedenfalls
sitzt jetzt hier gerade vom hauptgebäude
auch so liegestühle die hier irgendwie
für das campusleben von den studierenden
so ein bisschen rum sind das wetter ist
verraten nicht allzu gut also ist ein
bisschen bedeutet kalt aber es gibt halt
einfach an der jahreszeit derzeit und am
deutschen wetter hat allgemein die vorne
wird gerade wieder mit der drohne
solltest dir noch um gespielt und
umgeschaut da hinten sehe ich auch
gerade kommt noch ein roboter ich bin
auf jeden fall jetzt hierdurch bei der
fachhochschule brandenburg ist bei mega
cool also wirklich das mit der brille
aufsetzt ist das ja noch nie gemacht zu
oculus listenmäßig wird das vielleicht
bald auf einem kanal machen weil es ist
echt so krass dass orange will was ich
gespielt habe war von der grafiker
natürlich nicht so krass wie in hd
spiele auf der konsole oder so aber es
war einfach durch dieses 3d 4d erlebnis
einfach mega cool und hat dann das mit
der drohende mit dem roboter mit dem 3d
das war alles wow cool man denkt halt
auch immer direkt dass dieser
studiengang informatik das wird immer so
ein bisschen trocken an aber was ich
hier heute halt einfach gelernt habe ist
die entwickeln spiele die drehen filme
die machen das design von spielen die
machen 3d sachen die machen iphone-apps
roboter programmieren die also einfach
krass ich fliege jetzt zurück und dann
mach ich doch mal gesamte
ich
ich befinde mich gerade im nächsten
match auf meiner neuen wohnung
deswegen halte es auch noch sehr krass
ich hoffe euch hat dieses video gefallen
denn ich habe wahrscheinlich wie es
gemerkt habt am anfang ein bisschen was
neues ausprobiert mit der musik und dem
klatschen und an dem randen zoomen was
vox angeht ich will die blogs nicht so
gestalten wie es jeder youtuber macht so
ich zeig euch was lover musik mit zähnen
sondern ja so wie ihr das seht ich wurde
wie es am anfang der kampagne schon
gesagt habe im rahmen der kampagne mein
kampf studierenden auch eingeladen und
es war tatsächlich ganz geil das sage
ich jetzt nicht weil ich dafür 30
milliarden euro auf sein konto
überwiesen bekommen sondern weil es
wirklich einfach cool war ich konnte mit
robotern spielen ich konnte motion
capture aufnahmen machen
ich konnte bei videospielen die seite zu
schauen und so weiter und so fort es war
mega cool die wohnungen sind mega
günstig die ausstattung der unis habt
ihr ja schon gesehen war einfach nur
mega krank was diese ganzen sachen
angehen es ist halt einfach von den
standortfaktoren übels geil
das muss ich wirklich sagen das hätte
ich wirklich vorher überhaupt nicht
gepasst ich habe euch in die
beschreibung so 360 grad tour sachen
gemacht da könnt ihr euch diese uni noch
mal selbst bzw die verschiedenen unis
und hochschulen selbst in 360 grad
anschauen wenn ihr euch dafür
interessiert könnt ihr da gern mal
vorbeischauen ich kann jedem nur ans
herz legen irgendwas zu machen mit
seinem leben ich sehe leute die ihre
schule wegschmeißen und ihr studium und
ihre ausbildung um youtube zu machen
oder irgendetwas anderes aber man
braucht freunde so toll ich jetzt auch
finde sein leben zu leben und zu reisen
und alles mögliche zu machen braucht man
irgendwas im leben wenn es irgendwie
nicht mehr läuft man muss irgendetwas in
der tasche haben auch wenn es nur das
abitur ist nicht nicht
hochschulreife master bachelor
doktortitel blau auch wenn es nur ein
abi ist irgendwas muss man in der tasche
haben und deswegen finde ich es einfach
cool dass diese unis halt wirklich
einfach die bieten coole sachen an und
das wollte ich euch einfach zeigt
vielleicht sagte dass ich ein langweiler
bilden dadurch dass ich studiere neben
youtube und nicht jeden tag in einem
anderen land bin aber ich möchte lieber
irgendwie so ein bisschen so einen
ausgleich haben youtube ansicht wäre mir
zu langweilig an sich einfach so das
war's jetzt noch mal so ein bisschen am
ende hier gequatsche ich hoffe euch ja
das wie gefallen als das getan hat
schreibt mir eine bewertung und dann
sehen wir uns in einem anderen video
wieder ciao